alyssa is with us in Des Moines Iowa hi
Alyssa how are you hi Dave thank you so
much for taking my call
sure what's up okay this is a financial
as well as an ethical question my mom
passed away four years ago and I am
trying to figure out if I should finance
it she left me the house a hundred
percent but she said right before she
passed away she wanted me if I ever go
to sell the house to give them each
fifteen thousand dollars and I am trying
to figure out if I should finance that
because they would like their money now
if I should finance it or if I should
just continue trying showed up I'm sorry
that wasn't the deal they don't get
their money now unless you're selling
the house right it's what your mother
said she said if you ever go to sell the
house you should give them fifteen
thousand out of the sale right right so
why why did they get the idea they
should get it if you're not selling the
house because they say it's not fair
well I don't care what's fair fair is
the thing we have at the county where
they sell cotton candy and your mother
gave her very distinct wishes to you she
a left you the house and verbally not in
writing asked you to honor her last
wishes which was to give someone fifteen
thousand each out of the sale a house
should you ever sell the house correct
correct yeah and so it's not fair they
need to take it up with your mom okay
does this was her wishes all right it's
kind of to do with that I know one just
keep this brief but I got divorced four
years ago and I had twenty thousand
dollars a day I'm down to five I've got
two part-time jobs they have also
through this summer I mean I should be
able to save up and also pay them off
just keep financial peace correct I mean
how long I think I would you try them
all because they're really upset with me
they're not upset with you they're upset
with your mother this is her deal okay
you know that's true that is very true
this is the you know you did not do this
they're the ones changing the deal
and you you know your duty-bound to
honor your mother's wishes yes she was
worker wishes she did not say you know
for you to go borrow money to pay off to
buy out your brother and sister right
yes that is true I mean what if we were
they involved in the conversation with
your mom no they didn't have anything to
do with her for two and a half years
before she passed away Oh we'll see
there's always that in there yeah I
guess you're right so now these guys are
entitled to her money who they had
nothing to do with so your mom was very
clear and really she just at the last
minute had a little bit of compassion on
these kids who had dissed her well they
came around about the last five weeks
and that's when she said that no okay
okay all right well you know what I
would do is is without this is your full
brother and sister half brother sister
what full brother and sister okay
I would just sit down with them and
virgin are you you're not married you're
single and you know um just smile and
say you know I love you guys this was
mom's directions I'm going to abide by
mom's directions when I sell the house
you will get $15,000 if I never sell it
you never will
okay I just didn't know with the ethical
parts of it and what you saw you thought
well listen here here's the ethics
here's the ethics this is not about what
they want this is not about what you
want the ethics are following your
mother's instructions of what she wanted
done with her estate they are completely
out of line I'm kind of mad at them
right now just listening to this okay
misbehaving on a regular basis as these
twos pattern you know it but it caused a
lot of family turmoil they don't have a
lot to do with me anymore so how they
didn't have anything do with your mother
I guess that's a good point too yeah and
you know darling if you have to buy a
relationship that's called
prostitution no never thought of it that
way but yes you're very that is very
true you know and so if the only way
you're going to have anything to do with
me is me giving you money then we don't
have a relationship
I'm just your ATM access to money that
you think somehow you're entitled to but
you're not entitled to anything mom had
the money mom said what to do with the
money so now all of that said if you go
make two million dollars and you want to
write these two goober check to just but
let me just tell you they're never going
to be okay they're never going to be
okay because they didn't get their third
of the house because of the way they
treated your mother that's true and so
they're always going to have a chip on
their shoulder because this whole deal
every time they look at you they are
reminded of their misbehavior with their
mother and so it's always going to be
tension in the air unless somebody has a
spiritual healing in this process so I
think it's going to be really healthy
exercise for you to set reasonable
boundaries to these two bullies okay and
then if you decide to have mercy later
it's coming from you having strength not
you being pushed around
because I really sense in this
conversation they're doing a lot of
pushing around okay am I wrong I know
you're completely right thank you so
much I'm kind of using my voice like
Stern like growly right now to insert
insert strength into your backbone are
you feeling that I sure AM alright and I
want you to read a book called
boundaries by dr. Henry cloud because I
definitely do that
your brother and sister have in
appropriate boundaries hold on I'll have
Kelley pick up I'll give you a copy of
it because this is exactly what's going
on here thank you for the call folks
that illustrates right there why you not
only have a will but you also have a
reading of the will while you're alive
you tell people you know you have
anything to do with me for the last
two-and-a-half years so when Alyssa
sells the house but not until I've asked
her to give you fifteen thousand button
that happens you have no rights you have
no entitlement because you haven't been
here thank you for coming back into my
life in the last two weeks before I die
but you get this is what you get and you
have a reading of the will and if
someone's going to be angry we need to
go ahead and handle that while your life
you people get your wills and tell your
family what the will says this is not a
movie where a will is read in a walnut
paneled office by a an attorney and the
trophy wife is standing there with a
dysfunctional son this is not a movie
you cover your estate plan with your
family while you're alive this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show I want to write a
song I want to own my own business I
want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish
you